oh
[Musique]
en
on
à
community management c'est tout ce qui
va être communication sur les réseaux
sociaux cybersécurité c'est la personne
qui va contrôler le fait qu'ils aient
pas de piratage sur les systèmes web
designer c'est celui qui dessine en fait
les sites internet d'haïti c'est donc
intelligence des objets s'élevaient les
objets connectés des boîtes pour finir
pour le coup c'est pas l'interface et le
codage c'est vraiment la construction
des sites
[Musique]
j'ai été aidé parce que je suis débutant
on apprend vraiment le numérique il ya
un suivi de cette personne un suivi
individuel que c'est vraiment bien fait
bien organisée je suis pas venu dans un
but très précis juste venu pour
découvrir les métiers du numérique je
suis très intéressé par le métier de
webdesigner et des web là je suis dans
l'approfondissement du métier de
webdesigner et je vais certainement
poursuivre ma part la formation de six
mois
[Musique]
j'ai créé une entreprise en tant
qu'assistante indépendante depuis
janvier qui a été immatriculé et l'idée
c'est de pouvoir accompagner des
entrepreneurs des chefs d'entreprise
dans leur gestion administrative
j'ai créé la société moderne comme il ya
un an environ moderne comme c'est une
micro entreprise c'est une agence de
communication qui propose de la
prestation de services dans la
communication et dans la gestion de la
communication en général mais digital en
particulier des petites entreprises et
moyennes entreprises
[Musique]
business plan étude de marché statut
juridique etc stratégie communication et
digital on a vraiment été encadrée et
vous est donné à un b à ba vraiment pour
débuter en toute connaissance de cause
quand j'ai regardé le programme il y
avait une formation condensé mais qui
répondait à toutes les attentes qu un
jeune entrepreneur ou un entrepreneur en
devenir peut avoir
on
la première promotion a suivi jusqu'au
bout la formation et nous avons eu six
créations à l'issue de cette formation
nous avons une nouvelle édition donc
l'appel à candidatures est en cours
jusqu'au 30 juin à la fin du mois à
l'issue il ya un jury de sélection début
juillet pour intégrer la promo dont qui
démarrera du 12 septembre 16 décembre
[Musique]